take it away John
what's up reject nation you know what
I'm John Humphrey
this is Greg Alva and we're gonna check
out a music video today but none other
than the most insanely popular korean
band in the world BTS and before we hop
into this reaction just want to mention
to you guys you've probably never heard
this before but over on our page around
we got a special reward tier where any
video that you request we must
definitely cover and put up here on the
YouTube channel we got a whole bunch of
other stuff over there as well so if you
like TV show reactions music video
reactions q and A's etc community come
check us out over there patreon.com
slash the real rejects and become a
patron jerk today this is a special
request from patron jag Natalie Doran
our lovely friend Oh from Ireland I'm
trying really hard not to do some kind
of silly Irish accent for once in my
life but uh we checked out one of their
other songs just recently and now we're
gonna check out another one called fake
love I don't know anything about this
video usually there's some cinematic
stuff in the videos also shouts have to
spree over at the patreon for sending
this long as well got a lot of requests
for this video so I'm excited to check
it out oh and uh you know the way
YouTube is with music videos and stuff
we've got to cut this down because
otherwise it's gonna get blocked
worldwide or at very least a pesky
copyright claims so uh sorry there's not
really a whole lot we can do here if you
want to see the full cut come check it
on our patreon
let's happen in this video and a one and
A two
crow ticks oh yeah crud John does music
video coverage on our page front page by
the way yeah I mentioned that I don't
listen to you tell me what I'm doing
can't hear you only music
[Music]
[Music]
I grew up flower that can't be
[Music]
you guys are so famous you're gonna get
a lot of pay you know
[Music]
the different paceman worse one
[Music]
this is the most upbeat sadness I've
ever witnessed people
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
you just gotta be yourself man I mean
get these guys personal life advice I
noticed there you got a song about it
send it back
[Music]
yeah
below
it's a metaphor let's imagine the house
we saw to make a love take a love I like
I said
are we down the drain
[Music]
I'm worried so beautiful
fascinating
and is that that flower he was talking
about petals in it
call back to that motif I pay attention
alaric shop
[Music]
you know Wow
[Music]
they can love oh god it's so cool victim
[Music]
I grew flower that can't be bloomed that
isn't true is that get like it won't
open
gotcha you know like so was that one was
that the flower when he picked up this
it looked like samborose probably like
ashes could be in and the little
remnants of the petals floated away in
the wind I think it pick up on that very
selectively here astute observations I
mean it was a fun song no I
every BTS I've only heard a handful up
into this point but I always admire the
way that they're able to approach these
sort of well-worn pop ideas with a
little bit of a unique angle every
single time I mean I like the kind of
hook of this song about trying to fill a
standard or to kind of create an
illusion in order to maintain something
with somebody you know I thought it was
kind of a nice way to approach this kind
of more somber love song you know no hmm
and I mean the production values on
these videos yeah I'd like the lyrics of
this song I mean it's pretty easy to
grasp on to if you pay attention someone
all of them who are dating the same
woman just think it's weird girl there's
four guys in one girl girl you're seeing
that axis of awesome business I've been
sending up the back not too much for
this stuff oh well that's because my
talents are quite limited they do like
this whole parody of a boy band and it's
everything that you've ever thought it's
that idea of a man just couldn't be
himself in this relationship and he was
so in love that he kept changing who he
was in order to try to keep her happy
and he was pretending that he was happy
when really he wasn't and weirdly from
people this famous I can believe that
you know like something like that when
you're that popular I don't know if they
write their own lyrics you guys can
educate us and tell us from what I've
been told from Albion Spree over on the
patreon it seems like I mean I'm sure
that there are a lot of people involved
with this music but from what I gather
they are pretty and
of themselves in the making of the music
and the road lyrics and stuff well yeah
at first I thought it was coming from a
standpoint of you know because of who
they are they received a lot of like
phony kind of love no one really loves
them for who they are but then as I got
a little deeper I was like oh they're in
a relationship and they constantly have
to sign of a good codependent
relationship is what we're talking about
here draw both ideas out of it in
different ways and that's kind of the
fun of that yeah sure that some of this
does just apply to not all of it but it
does apply to their position people and
I like the trapped idea of this
relationship which is usually these
toxic codependent cases where he's in a
room that's smaller than waters filling
us who's drowning in this relation yeah
in other room fire or as they're trying
to run away the ground is falling so
it's like catching up to them and
they're about to fall into it even
deeper like those visual representations
I think I mean I only saw the other one
that we did together and I think I like
this one even more actually the other
one was like cool badass and froat it's
that idea even goes back because that
whole metaphor is about not trying to be
something that you aren't because you
won't be able to fulfill that and then
you'll kind of crash and burn and that's
sort of what this song is getting at
with yeah I can be a bunch of things for
you but they're all kind of not what I
am true you know and on the visual side
the production value is again are always
gorgeous I mean just like the use of
colors and all these different right
tableaus and sets and everyone's a
little bit different they've all got
their own concept you got this one with
like phones all over the walls and then
you have the drains stuff which seems
like kind of a through-line metaphor cuz
you know after the drain bit he shows up
in that big old like water ya room and
stuff and the candy you know he probably
took that as like hey I'm I like candy
yeah that's the metaphors he just really
wants to eat candy it's way I could be
anything so rich that that he was I was
his footage from his vlog yeah
just bought a bunch of candy laid on it
and once a day he eats ten candies we
need an extra shot something decadent
what do you got for me or or Snickers
sponsored them and they're like how do
we get Snickers in why not man well
that's the thing is like to it no I took
it that's you know like being sweet
that's the funny thing I think about all
these is the the oscillation like this
especially has the not today video was
very kind of action moving very outdoors
and this is more like scenery oriented
to me and so yeah to have all these
Snickers bars as this visual metaphor of
sweetness is almost so much it's like
eating too much candy in and of itself
yeah I don't know there's so many
beautiful images that that whole like
sculpture thing there in front of at the
beginning almost looks like they're in
some kind of modern art you see yeah you
know I could dance like these guys I
played Dance Central and Xbox Kinect
which people still used well people
before we wrap this thing up one to give
a quick patron shout out to miss Natalie
Doran of course for requesting this
video but also just for being awesome
and for taking kit your attractive is
what that means you know you're about
the credits you know that's what I like
the most about shoes you never try to be
something that you're not you're not a
croats it Natalie you are yourself and
you do the Lord's work helping out the
elderly of Ireland and then going out
and drinking on the weekends you know
that sounds like very fulfilling duality
of life and I cannot wait for you to
join us next year
Florida's out of the picture you come
into LA we're gonna kick it you're gonna
react to on these videos with us and
it's gonna be a little bit awkward but a
lot a bit fun so uh and and yeah we're
gonna make eye contact yeah prolonged
eye contact eye contact mm-hmm and I'm
gonna be listening
to the eye contact you know I'm talking
about sure why not it's you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification about to get an
updated every time a reviewer a video is
out check us out on the patreon falls on
the Stardust app and have yourself a
nice day peace
I I'm sure the newest dance Central has
a ton of BTS songs
I don't think connected production on
Xbox one okay they've got to have a way
I think the people comment below let me
know all right then I'll cut it maybe I
won't cut it out then I'll I'll put it
at the end after the I drain part with
our bumper ok it's good